can i get some milk and sugar with my
coffee please
now that is some awesome coffee
translation is fun isn't it
well stay with me as we explore custom
translation models to power global apps
welcome to ai adventures where we
explore the arts
science and tools of machine learning i
am priyanka vergaria and today we are
talking about
custom translation models i was in peru
last year
which was mostly a spanish-speaking
country i do not speak spanish so i had
to rely
on google translate for even minor
things such as
can i get milk in my coffee please now
imagine if i was to go
live and work in peru for a year helping
developers implement machine learning
and ai may be the machine
learning field has unique terms and
references to mathematical concepts
which
might not be captured in a standard
dictionary for a custom use case like
this the standard translation api
may not be sufficient to provide the
best experience i would need to make
sure
things don't get lost in translation and
that would need a custom model specific
to the ml and ai terminologies
to communicate effectively with the
spanish-speaking developers this is
probably true in your field as well
that's where automl translation comes to
rescue
automl translation lets you create your
own
custom translation models so that
translation queries return
results specific to your domain to
understand this further
let's take another example imagine you
run a financial reporting service that
has an
opportunity to expand to peru india and
france those markets require that your
time
sensitive financial documents are
translated in real time
automl translation can help you automate
the translation job for over 100
language pairs in a scalable way
allowing you to enter those newer
markets quickly
now you might be asking yourself when
would i use automl
over the translation api translation api
does a great job with general purpose
text
and with advanced glossary features you
can take it further
by providing a dictionary of words or
phrases i covered this in detail in the
previous episode linked below
but there are times when you don't have
a glossary or know exactly which word
translations
you want to control automl translation
shines in those cases in that last while
between
generic translation tasks and specific
niche vocabularies
what's amazing is automl's custom model
is built
on top of the generic translation api
model for domain specific content that
matters to you
now let's say you've established that
you need a custom translation model
how would you create one well we will
just prepare and source the data and
feed it into auto ml translation
it then trains deploys and serves the
model and provides us with an easy
interface to evaluate and test it
it creates an easy to use rest api to
make predictions
high quality data is critical ingredient
in creating an effective automl
translation model
as a general best practice make sure
your sentence pairs
do the best possible job of covering the
vocabulary
usage and grammatical quirks of your
industry
or the area of focus for more details
i've included a link in the description
for some best practices on how to assess
and source your data once we have the
data
we head over to the automl translation
ui and create the data set
by selecting the source and target
language upload the files from your
computer and select the folder in cloud
storage for these files to be stored
when successfully uploaded we can review
our data set
and the sentence pairs with the data all
set we are ready to train the model
but this step can take several hours
depending on the amount of data
so let's grab coffee in the meantime all
right it looks like our training is
complete
and right here it is showing us the high
level metrics for our model
and its bleu or bilingual evaluation
under study score which takes a ground
truth translation and compares it to
a machine translation the more overlap
between the human and machine output
the higher the blu score you can see the
score for google's base model
and your custom model as well as the
difference between them
in this case we see a boost of a few
points over the base model
now the moment of truth let's head over
to our predict tab to test our model
we can even compare the results from our
custom model
to the google nmt which is the neural
machine translation model
to see the difference in this episode we
learned how automl translation helps you
create
high quality production-ready custom
translation models
quickly how are you using the automl
translation model
in your use cases share with me in the
comments below
thank you for watching this episode of
cloud ai adventures and if you enjoyed
it click that like button
and be sure to subscribe to get all the
latest episodes right when they come out
i look forward to seeing you next time
on ai adventures
where we will talk about federated
learning
you